I'm getting hard just thinking about it
man
I think you might be onto something big
here man I like this I like where your
head's at you Loosely graze the subject
of a life-changing LSD experience yes
that is correct Burning Man family
vacation to burning man what happened
um
what was the trip like the trip was
I went to my own funeral I watched my
death play out um yeah basically
I watched my life play out as a drug
addict this was kind of at like my very
very bottom bottom and um how old were
you this was when I was 17 I believe it
was right before my senior year in high
school with the burning man with your
parents at 17. yeah and I was this is
right when I was kind of rekindling my
relationship with them because that
summer I had been kicked out I was doing
different hard drugs every day just
mixing them all together as well and
selling hard drugs to survive and my
friends were cool enough to let me live
at their houses so it wasn't like I was
homeless I had people that took care of
me but like you know it was like very
dark period of my life and um that's the
difference between a homeless person and
a couch Surfer right is charisma
and con Artistry which I think you and I
both have faded out very well
but yeah basically you know I was in a
very low place and um with that I kind
of I was supposed to meet my parents the
night of the burn so
I've been kind of doing my own thing
seeing like the concerts and stuff on my
own and like the last night was the
night of the burnout supposed to meet
with my parents and
um the Playa is super massive and
there's no I don't know how it is now
but when I went there's definitely no
cell phone reception right have you been
no I I uh consider that a no-fly zone
bro I feel like that you would have the
time of your life there I mean I know
they have like you know sober
communities there you don't need to be
are you in a you can't be around people
that partake it's not that I can't be
around it I just have to like have a
legitimate reason for being there and
it's well it's just like the craziest
art performance of all time I mean
people spend their whole year is making
these art vehicles that are like you
know pirate ships driving through we'll
go to the next one it's pretty wild I
think that's perfectly Fair
um my other you have to go dude no I'm
not here to sell you on it I only went
one time it's not like I'm a burner
right my other Prejudice is that I don't
really like being around in a big crowd
oh I'm right there with you there's a
lot of work but you can wear a disguise
bro yeah oh yeah I mean everybody people
everyone's wearing like things covering
their face from the the dust so talking
about YouTube we went to this YouTube
convention the remote was gonna get out
of VidCon and um I was like man walking
around the YouTube convention it's gonna
be a lot of work dude I'm gonna like get
a disguise you know and so I went and
bought a stormtrooper
costume at the costume store and I go to
the VidCon and everybody's stopping me
to take pictures with the Stormtroopers
you spent too much money on it dude
now you said you you saw your funeral
like like get deeper into that okay so
what happened was anyways I'm supposed
to meet my parents we missed the
Rendezvous spot and basically I brought
acid a bunch there thinking hey like I'm
gonna try to do with my family and they
were my my parents were kind of open to
the idea but it seemed like it maybe
wasn't gonna happen but anyways like I
take this acid and I'm supposed to meet
up with them at this thing but I didn't
have any water and I was like oh I think
I have enough time to go back to where I
was staying and get water and come back
and or no I was like I didn't have time
to meet them back there before they come
here and I went and then they were gone
the people I was with they're like they
already left and then they real that was
when it clicked to me I'm like oh you're
not going to be finding your family
because it's just mass chaos the night
of the burn it's always chaos there but
and you're not allowed to spend money
everything's barter yeah pretty much I
mean you could buy coffee you can buy
coffee and ice and water I thought that
like as I understood it money is no good
like but you have to pay like a ton of
money to get in there you know I don't
know it's not cheap so but the idea is
really cool concept of like sharing and
um kind of just like trading but going
back to the story so anyways the whole
thing the trip starts by me missing my
parents which was supposed to be like a
really epic special thing we all went to
Burning Man with the intention to spend
this beautiful night together so I'm
just like start frying off out of my
mind on acid and like I was like I had
taken I had like a bunch of the
strongest assets I've ever gotten I
bought like half a sheet from my friend
and it was double dose to begin with but
then I had taken it to some different
festivals and things were as hot and I I
was like okay there's probably heat
damage this may be and I don't know like
what's the idea behind that that I had
in my mind but it was certainly not and
I was like oh I'll just take extra and
so I took a bunch which was like the
equivalent of probably eight tabs or
something like that and I just I just
fried out of my mind to the point where
like the burning was happening of this
giant man he's like 50 I don't know how
much 100 feet tall some crazy number
he's Giant and they burn this thing it's
like a sacrifice and then I'm just like
in my mind all of a sudden I'm like next
to the BBC there's like real like news
sources documenting and I'm like oh I'm
here to give a speech like in my mind I
thought I was and I'm like giving the
speech about how incredible burning man
is and then all of a sudden there's
cameras everywhere around me like
hundreds of them people are closing in
on me with video cameras and news
reporters and I'm like get the [__] away
from me like I was having open eye
full-on delusional because what I guess
what happened was I got hungry and then
I ate a bunch of weed brownies that my
parents made but the weed brownies were
so strong that normally you would just
pass out your eyes go bloodshot but when
you're on acid you don't fall asleep so
it was like that's probably what pushed
the edge to the next level as well
because like it started getting super
paranoid and I think the weed brownies
was a big part of that and also maybe
taking the hallucinations to another
level because I never had those types of
hallucinations on LSD but maybe I just
never had taken quite enough you know
but it was so crazy so they're closing
in on me and I'm like riding this big
wheel chopper bike through the desert
I'm like get the [__] away from me I'm
like cruising down like I don't give a
[__] if I hit anybody like I'm ready to
just plow them down I'm going through
and I start overheating it's essentially
like a PCP type moment I know you used
to do dabble I love that [__] so I
started overheating I'm like oh my God I
gotta rip all my clothes off I'm
completely naked I had a backpack filled
with like ounce and a half of mushrooms
I just throw everything that I had the
bike down I'm just like running and I'm
like I gotta get out of here I gotta get
I think all these like devils and things
are trying to kill me and I'm like start
going into this like dark reality where
I'm basically
I at some point like collapse and I see
my eyes are playing movies they're open
but I'm just watching movies and it
shows my naked body on the front page of
the newspaper and it's like boy
overdoses at Burning Man and then I'm
transported to my funeral and I hear all
my families there my intermediate Aunts
Uncles cousins grandma and parents and
whatever and everyone's just weeping
like he was such a good kid but he did
so much drugs so I essentially had
watched my life play out as a drug
addict like there was a moment before
that where I was running and I went from
like this light around me that like
because that day or the day before I
found out I was gonna play my first big
DJ event so I feel like there was this
like light that was around me and I was
like ran further and further out into
the desert the light disappeared and I
was just in darkness all alone as and I
watched myself age from my childhood to
an old weathered out old Skeleton Man
and then at that point I died that was
this whole thing I watched my life play
out as an addict and then basically I
was so high I couldn't even see I was
just watching movies I'm running through
the desert and there's the outside
parameter fence which is a snow fence I
couldn't even see it I was so [__]
high hallucinating these things that I
flip over my body's cut covered in but
like cuts on my dick I'm sure you know
how that is with some of your stunts
um especially the ball sack stapling
yeah I I've been there man I keep
running though I'm like I gotta get the
[__] out of here this is hell like I'm
trapped in this never-ending Rave hell I
thought I was like there's like all
these Rave things and I would be going
in circles and it was just like I
thought I was paying for my sins as a
raver almost like the rave music was
just never ending and I'm like running
out there trying to escape this hell
realm and I eventually like and I'm just
my body's like I'm trying to rip when I
was on the ground I try to hit my I
think I'm dead right but my body is
still going I don't understand it
exactly but it was almost as if my brain
had been destroyed my body was still
going so I was on the ground
hitting my head against the bottom
desert floor which is incredibly hard
and I was hitting my head pulling on my
hair trying to pull my brain out of my
head and so it was this crazy thing so
my head's now warped I'm covering Cuts
I'm running as far as I can my feet are
covered in Cuts because I'm running on
rocks and stuff and eventually at a
certain point I can't down enough I'm
like there's nothing out here I gotta
and I see the light in the distance like
miles out I could have easily died it's
like freezing out there and it's like
probably 2 A.M in the morning and I'm
just like running out there and then I'm
like there's something in the distance I
was like I gotta go to the light and
that was the Burning Man
The Burning Man had already been burnt
but the actual event the the festival is
filled with lights and craziness so I
was running towards that I saw it in the
distance yeah they have like a big
ferris wheel kind of they got everything
you could imagine but yeah I'm saying
like giant rubber ducky disco text you
know it's just like a crazy art scene we
could have this RV there and you've got
to kick it in the RV you could interview
all the people out of their mind on
ketamine yeah but long story short then
I like hopped over this fence because I
could see again and I'm running in and
all of a sudden there's like a ranger
basically they have people guarding the
parameter this was like when I'd come
down enough that my mine was melted but
I could still see again and they were
like did you just sneak in I was like
fully naked I was like sneak in from
where like so I like run into the thing
and now I'm like entering into a party
of 60 000 people I'm completely naked
and I don't have my clothes and I'm like
streaking through this party what
happened to the backpack full of
mushrooms lost it all I was thinking
about that
because that mushrooms I used to sell
mushrooms and there are mushrooms that I
was gonna sell to people and then my
parents found them that was part of like
the reason too like that was part of
around that era was like when I got
kicked out and um basically
they gave me the mushrooms back that I
give it away to people that Burning Man
so it was always supposed to be a gift
to the burners but anyways long story
short I come back and I'm like freezing
after hours I'm covered in cuts my
mind's fried out of just completely
useless I couldn't even remember where I
was staying if I wanted to and so I was
just walking around freezing and these
this woman I started like weeping I was
just had to hit such a crazy rock bottom
and This Woman's like are you okay I'm
like not really I don't really know
where to go I lost everything I don't
know where I'm staying and she's like oh
come with me and like she took me back
and like her friends were there and they
gave me this giant cloak and then they
gave me like some water and some cookies
and nurtured me it's that's the cool
thing of Burning Man everyone's kind of
looking out for each other you know
there's a lot of like love in the air
and maybe that's not everyone there's a
lot of random people who show up and are
there to frap row party out or whatever
but the core is kind of this like very
loving experience are the people like
bartering sex and [__] I don't think so
but there's definitely orgies and stuff
like that and there's probably like uh
you know six foot nitrous tanks
people around you would be in heaven
back hold you yeah
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude